Up.
Sometimes we wish we never had to
deal with this morning struggle,
but what if you just never went to bed?
What if you figured out how to
keep yourself awake forever?
How long could the sleepless forever last?
Could you even be productive while
they were charging every night?
When would your friends start telling
you to get some rest and what exactly
would happen to your boss?
This is what if and here's what
would happen if you stopped sleeping.
How often have you needed just a few
more hours to finish off a project?
Get ready for a date
or enjoy your day off?
If you took sleep out
of your daily routine,
you'd have all 24 hours in the day to
do everything he never had time for.
What's a few yards and some
minor tiredness. If in men,
you never have to waste any more
time lying in bed for no good reason.
Turns out there are plenty
of good reasons to sleep.
The average person spends one
third of their life lying in bed.
I shut snoring away.
Sounds like a waste of valuable time,
but not for your body. While you sleep,
your body releases hormones and repairs,
tissues, replacing your old cells with
new ones. If you worked out that day,
you need a good sleep to let your
muscles grow and your fat burn.
So what happens if you don't sleep?
Not much at first, after just 24 hours,
you'd feel completely fine. In
fact, you'd feel better than fine.
That's because sleeplessness stimulates
the mesolimbic pathway in your brain.
This pathway would release dopamine and
you'd feel happy and full of energy,
but don't be fooled by all that
happiness is not going to last long.
Soon after reaching the 24 hour mark,
all your reactions would slow down.
Your brain would start to forget
what you were doing outwardly.
You'd appear to be drunk. Wait
where? Where are we right now?
What about two days without sleep?
At that point,
your body would start shutting down.
It would stop metabolizing
glucose properly leaving
you with no energy supply.
You'd start looking very pale. Your eyes
would turn red and then more bad news,
your wrinkles,
it would become more visible on day three.
That's when the real fun begins.
Hallucinations starved of rem sleep.
Your brain would bring all your dreams
and nightmares to life at around the 72
hour mark, you start breaking down
your own protein, your muscles.
So say goodbye to all that muscle mass
you've worked so hard to build up.
Your body would keep using up all the
energy sources that could find glucose,
leftovers, your muscles, fat
tissue. After about two weeks,
your immune system would be so weak.
You could die from the common flu.
Eventually,
three weeks after your last sleep,
you'd probably die of a heart attack.
If you've got a little extra
muscle or fat on your body,
you could stay alive just a bit longer.
But we don't recommend anyone
try this at home anyway.
So grab yourself a
pillow and take a siesta.
If it seems like you're always tired,
make sure you're getting the prescribed
six to eight hours of sleep per night.